the thing the thing that blew my mind I
had no idea I had never heard before not
to do with judging but sort of
interrelated the statistics the
statistics that the UFC puts up for
significant strikes every single strike
at distance is considered significant it
could be the lightest jab the lightest
distance finding job ever it's
significant I don't know why but for
whatever reason that is how they've
defined it so I need to watch the
mirabazi kaikov France fight again
because I think that that might have
played a really big role because it
makes no sense to me that we count a
distance finding job as significant but
the judges are specifically no no we
only judge on damage like those those
are poor opposite things I agree so
we're showing the audience a number that
says there were X number of significant
strikes and in my mind I'm like oh
significant means that they did damage
absolutely not